are the raddest looking human ever like
we like things I dream of in my head I'm
like I could try this like you pull off
all of them I just don't want to feel
like I look in the mirror and I look
conservative and straight I know someone
you know like you know sometimes they
pierce Brooks Brothers and I think to
myself well that ain't bad I'm like what
do you mean I love my legs looks where
she and me too
but you know like really being in like a
pinstripe suit was like you know like my
real color hair which I haven't seen
since I was 9 I was I don't think you're
ever gonna be able to fight rock and
roll I think that's just gonna naturally
exude from you that's what we love about
you but you'll never met before
yeah we have you know in her show in my
show but I agree with you as soon as I
look too proper I'm like oh you know I
don't know what older artists look like
I feel like this like just now you look
beautiful you're not old
in what age time you don't do I'm just
I'm gonna be basic Betty though even at
70 like I'm cool with it that's who I am
I'm like rolling with this Cindy went
way what I always think of is your song
what doesn't kill you you know that song
I do I feel bored you know I used to
like whenever I was feeling really kind
of way down trata I would like I love
seeing along with even hurt it you came
a chick oh my god well thank you
it's home for the holidays right we're
coming to LA usually we're in New York
but this year it's a special year we're
coming to la la la it's our big
fundraiser this year on well every year
it's it's the mean the main thing we do
for the true colors United it's a
organization that we did too to help
eradicate I guess youth homelessness and
that it ranges anywhere from 12 to 24
and what we discovered was that there's
3.7 million kids on the street one year
and up to 40% of them are LGBTQ which is
a lesbian or gay and you start to
realize that a lot of these kids are
getting thrown out of their homes as
they come out to their parents a mom you
never get the kid the kid isn't who you
want the kid to be the kid is all the
gate is I think it's so you know people
think it's better and it is but it's not
better everywhere and it's not better in
every house it comes from the bar that's
way down here then you've still only
made that's right you've got to have a
long way like guys it's not yeah I mean
we we've been trying but it's still up
to 40 percent yeah I just think that we
can do stuff with education and
different programs which we have been
involved with we bring a lot of
organizations together and outreach
programs together this is the work we do
we lobby we've had people from like 50
cent to I think pink floret pink yeah
Laverne Cox I think what's importantly
most important to like just to point out
I know you're not gonna say this but the
fact that you are unique and you aren't
original and a lot of the kids are
caught probably speaking to are unique
and very original
they stand out in their community the
fact that you're leading it up means all
the world we can rule you took your
platform though and you did something
that's it's a cool thing you know you
can't throw away our youth or uses or
future we're parents we stand by the
kids we have to because honestly you
won't have a future if you don't listen
to all right so where is this concert
happening at the Novo theater on
December 10th October 18th tickets go on
sale and that's true colors United org
and get all the information get
information about what we do together we
can actually change the situation and
once we take care of that I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this